[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport c'est parti pour le sommaire de
ce à magazine cyclisme le paris nice
était lancée ce dimanche depuis plaisir
pour la première fois de son histoire
aujourd'hui le peloton est parti depuis
chevreuse coup de projecteur dans ce
magazine c'est qu'ils sont encore les
six heures piste était organisée ce
samedi au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines des têtes
d'affiché des présentes comme morgan
kneisky retour sur cet événement dans ce
set 8 sport running samir bouffonne 28
ans est un adepte de la course à pied et
licencié à l'entente athlétique de saint
quentin divine ya déjà terminée a dit
marathon nous le recevrons dans ce au
magazine l'actualité sportive de la
semaine c'est maintenant sur tb sur 118
on commence tout de suite par du running
il a 28 ans il nous vient d'elancourt il
est un grand fan de course à pied il a
déjà réalisé 10 marathon samir nous
phoque est avec nous sur ce plateau bon
sens samedi soir alors nous vous avons
invités parce que vous deviez participer
au marathon de barcelone le 15 mars
prochain
mais le rendez-vous a été annulé à cause
du courant des virus il sera déplacé au
25 octobre votre réaction assez déçu
puisque évidemment comme tous les
participants s'est beaucoup entraîné on
s'est beaucoup préparé pour l'événement
mais depuis quinze jours déjà on sentait
que malheureusement si elle être annulée
donc là les déplace en octobre au moins
on aura le temps de tête mais
s'entraîner faire un meilleur temps donc
c'est pas grave alors ce report va vous
handicaper pour la suite de la saison ou
pas du tout pour l'instant c'est un
point du cap ans dans le sens où on se
prépare plutôt pour des courses on n'a
plus trop d'objectifs de cours sur maya
jusqu'au mois de mai je pensais que tout
va être annulée au fur et à mesure mais
bon c'est pas grave on commence déjà à
programmer des courses ou d'autre chose
pour la rentrée prochaine en septembre
et au contraire comme je les y en aura
plus de temps pour s'entraîner c'est pas
très grave
alors on va revenir sur votre passion
alors est-ce qu'on vous présentait les
origines de cette passion l'art je crois
que vous allez commencer en 2013
est ce que vous attendez pas en 2013
j'ai commencé avec le semi de paris
c'était un premier challenge
je voulais commencer à courir sur une
longue distance marathon ça en avait
l'air un peu trop gros début pour
commencer
et donc j'ai commencé par un semis
21 km et après commence à faire un
marathon l'année d'après à
toujours à paris et depuis il enchaîne
les courses grosso modo jean-yves en
faire une cinquantaine maintenant sept
ans que je cours et à peu près 10
marathon j'essaye d'en faire au moins un
voire deux parents et ses sapins que ça
dure et j'espère le plus longtemps
possible
est ce qu'on peut dire vous êtes accro
maintenant drogués si je peux dire à
cette discipline
oui bien sûr c'est vraiment on va dire
une addiction aujourd'hui je m'entraîne
à raison de quatre à six fois par
semaine
et peu importe quel emploi du temps peu
importe les moments je trouve toujours
un moment pour m'entraîner donc c'est
vraiment devenu une addiction comme tous
les coureurs des conques où on prend du
plaisir on progresse
au programme des courses et c'est bien
tout doucement où vous trouvez substance
ce plaisir c'est le dépassement soit
exactement le dépassement de soi le fait
de se fixer un objectif de l'atteindre
de l'heureux dépassé pour donner un
exemple j'ai commencé un semis en 2013
en 1h41
aujourd'hui mon encore il à 1h16 on voit
là la progression qui est palpable
on n'a pas concrètement et ça nous
pousse encore et encore à progresser et
toujours être contre le chrono et
comment réagit votre entourage à cette
addiction
maintenant ils sont habitués je suis
pour tout le monde je suis je suis un
coureur même dans mon quartier on
qualifie comme étant le coureur le
marathonien ils sont habitués donc ils
savent très bien que de samedi soir
c'est compliqué parce que le dimanche
matin c'est l'entraînement c'est la
sortie donc cédé 20 km donc tout le
monde est à être habitués et s'habitue
alors vous faites partie d'un club de le
à saint quentin en yvelines
pourquoi pourquoi le à 50 ans du bim
c'est un très bon club déjà et c'est un
club de l'agglomération qui est vraiment
un très bon niveau de running là cette
année j'ai un gros poids du temps donc
j'ai pas trois entraînements mais
j'essaie de faire en sorte dit d'y aller
c'est plus plus souvent et ça permet
d'avoir des techniques d'avoir un vrai
entraînement des des plans très précis
puisque c'est paradoxal mais quand on
court on doit apprendre à courir
on doit apprendre à voir une bonne foule
et apprendre à faire les bons exercices
et pas seulement courir donc c'est
important d'être encadrés par des gens
diplômés les professionnels qui vont
avoir des bonnes techniques pour
justement nous permettre de progresser
ça prend combien de temps justement pour
avoir ces techniques ça dépend des
personnes mais on va dire
1 1 et 2 ans on peut dire comprendre et
améliorer sa foulée améliorer son rythme
cardiaque et après c'est devenu une
habitude qu'on entretient alors le à 50
on élimine à plusieurs infrastructures
sur le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines
est ce que ça vous aide également
progressé bien sûr on a la chance
d'avoir des très beaux endroits ça parte
en yvelines pour ma part soit vu en
cours elle en cours ou alors je
m'entraînais vraiment beaucoup très
souvent tout seul à la base de loisirs
on a un très très beau cadeau avec lui
permet de s'entraîner dans de très très
bonnes conditions
donc c'est vrai que c'est un gros
avantage d'avoir tout ça autour de nous
en ce moment il fait pas forcément très
beau est-ce que vous avez quand même
envie de faire des sorties
honnêtement qui fasse froid qui fasse
chaud qui pleut c'est pas du tout un
frein dame au contraire des fois c'était
motivant de courir en température un peu
extrêmes donc pas du tout quand on est
vraiment passionnés la pluie le vent
c'est pas du toit un frein au contraire
limites qu'est-ce que vous donnerez
comme conseil quelqu'un qui veut se
lancer dans le voyou comme vous de
commencer tout doucement
malheureusement certains des fois vont
trop vite et commence par des grandes
distances mais et non de commencer par
courir tout doucement petite demi heure
20 minutes puis après deux augmenté un
peu la distance où le rythme si tout va
bien
et pourquoi pas si l'envi ce l'envi
vient de faire une course commençait par
un 10 km progressivement et on va voir
que ça va venir tout seul et on peut
justement se blesser c'est un sport dans
laquelle on peut se blesser facilement
donc fermement très attention à aller
trop vite
justement vous pas de blessure pour
l'instant pour l'instant ça va je n'ai
eu une grosse il ya cinq ans au niveau
de la cheville mais maintenant je fais
attention est justement le fait
d'apprendre à courir correctement avec
la bonne foulée ça permet justement
d'éviter un peu les blessures alors
l'objectif c'est la participation pour
vous la performance
un peu des deux ça dépend
on va dire il ya des courses qui sont
très importantes comme des grands
marathons comme new york que j'ai fait
récemment il ya trois mois
là c'est vraiment de participer après
évidemment à chaque fois il ya un gros
objectif de temps derrière donc c'est
vraiment un peu des deux tout dépend de
la course en question alors quels sont
vos prochains objectifs il y avait donc
ce marathon de berlin et qui a été
annulé à cause du corona virus quels
sont vos prochains objectifs
je pense barcelone en octobre vu qu'il a
été décalé après dans le running on a
des objectifs celui très long terme
moi pour ma part ce serait de faire les
six grands marathons dans le monde on
appelle les majors il ya new york boston
chicago londres berlin et tokyo
j'en ai déjà fait deux sur les 6 mon but
c'est abstrait 7-6 évidemment et après
pourquoi pas partir sur des distances
plus longues sur des trails ultra trail
et sur des 100 km sur du triathlon
souleimane
c'est de partir peut-être plus loin et
voir d'autres horizons dans le sport ce
sont des résistances qui vous
intéressent
exactement c est ce qu on se laisser vos
limites s'ajustant justement on prenait
pas vraiment les limites de son corps et
la course à pied nous montre à chaque
fois à chaque fois on pense que faire un
marathon c'est impossible et moi le
premier et au début pour moi c'était
inimaginable de faire 40 kilomètres sans
m'arrêter et maintenant c'est pas de
mine normal mais je le fais sans grand
grand grand problème
donc je pense que faire le double c'est
aussi faisable il seulement c'est un
beau challenge et c'est pour ça que on
aime beaucoup ce sport et qu'on devient
vraiment accro la question qu'est ce
qu'on peut vous souhaiter pour les
prochains mois les prochaines semaines
bah comme tout le monde
quel virus se calme qu'on puisse courir
faisant problème confie s'est entraîné
sans problème et bat pas de blessure et
ce sujet j'espère maintenant je suis à
deux doigts d'avoir le niveau pour avoir
les minima pour les championnats de
france
donc tout se passe bien et que les
musiques mais tous les adultes y soit
merci à vous ça venir dépasser sur ce
bateau continuera à suivre vos
performances dans les prochaines
semaines vers ses prochains mois merci
beaucoup
on continue par le paris nice 2020 la
course cycliste s'est élancé pour la
onzième année consécutive depuis les
yvelines cette année le peloton est
parti à ce dimanche depuis à plaisir
aujourd'hui les courants après le départ
depuis chevreuse coup de projecteur des
images de nicolas adam dry avantage de
sandrine fontaine
[Musique]
cette 78e édition du paris-nice par
depuis le 78 depuis les yvelines cette
année c'est la commune de plaisir qui a
été choisie pour être la première étape
de l'épreuve
une édition 2020 un peu particulière
dans les yvelines l'actualité sanitaire
du moment rattraper la course
cette équipe ont déclaré forfait juste
avant le début de l'épreuve à cause du
courant la virus il a fallu prendre tout
un tas de mesures plus tata de
chamboulement donc on a une une semaine
dernière très très très agitée là on
n'est pas encore sera 100%
on sait que qu'il faut vivre au jour le
jour mais on fait le maximum on prend
des mesures
quelques quelques règles différentes
sinon au total 17 équipes ont pris le
départ de l'épreuve ce dimanche 8 mars
les organisateurs avaient concocté une
boucle de 154 km dans les yvelines en
passant par montfort l'amaury touahri ou
encore neauphle-le-château on a fait un
parcours avec des changements de
direction constants on sait à peu près
depuis depuis quelques années que qu'il
ya cette époque de l'année ya beaucoup
de vent donc on essaye de mettre les
coureurs en difficulté et on avait aussi
pas mal de petites grimpettes
sympathique
c'est finalement le champion d'allemagne
maximilian sharman qui s'impose sur la
ligne d'arrivée à plaisir bien sûr je
suis très heureux c'est ma première fois
ici sur cette course c'était génial
le chouchou du public français julian
alaphilippe termine lui 4e je compte en
faire un beau final
dans les bordures et j'ai donné le
maximum
[Musique]
après une très belle première étape à
plaisir aujourd'hui
le départ sera donné depuis chevreuse
une petite commune de moins de 6000
habitants
direction le loiret pour une étape de
166 km
je suis avec madame le maire de
chevreuse madame le maire j'imagine que
vous êtes ravi d'accueillir ce
paris-nice ici assez fabuleux pour une
commune comme la nôtre c'est vraiment un
honneur et puis c'est vraiment un moment
génial à partager avec tous les
bénévoles tous ceux qui sont motivés
pour cette organisation on est vraiment
ravis et fiers d'accueillir le paris
nice où et quand ça se prépare justement
par une liste dans une ville alors c'est
un petit peu compliqué parce que voyez
notre commune c'est une rue principale
et ici elle est complètement bloquée
donc pas mal d'organisation en amont les
écoles les transports etc
le stationnement mais tout ça c'est
vraiment anticiper les le travail a été
fait depuis le mois de décembre
maintenant et je pense qu'on est à peu
près près et et voilà tout va bien se
passer on est on est vraiment ravis
heureux c'est une petite commune de
moins de 6000 habitants qui va être
connus au niveau mondial maintenant
alors j'espère qu'elle l'était déjà à on
a plein d'atouts qui font qu'on devait
déjà être connue donc j'espère que ce
sera juste une confirmation qu à
chevreuse ont fait de belles choses et
qu'on est ravi d'accueillir du public
pour des événements comme ça comme pour
d'autres et les spectateurs sont venus
en nombre autour de la ligne de départ
ils étaient plusieurs centaines de
curieux amateurs ou non de cyclisme je
suis pas mal de courses en belgique je
gars de liège malgré la pluie
aujourd'hui bornand du soleil c'est
qu'on sait pas quand on est fan suite
chevreuse et moi j'adore le vélo et je
viens toujours voir paris nice se
regarde toujours mes mates et les
meilleurs succès de départ à chevreuse
c'est mieux on voit tout le monde on
voit les voitures les vélos la ville de
chevreuse et la 19e ville d'eysines à
être village de départ de l'épreuve
si vous regardez bien c'est aussi la
tendance même sur le tour de france
d'organisateurs ce non pas ceux force
mais on peut grand plaisir à aller dans
des îles d'or des communes et ce pas
seulement dans les grandes villes
c'est plutôt sympa bien sûr c'est le
mélo c'est le sport de tout le monde le
départ a été donné à 12h25 sous les
applaudissements de la foule et des
enfants de la commune présent pour
l'événement
direction le loiret un pour les coureurs
rendez vous aux liens les prochaines
départ depuis les yvelines en 2021
pour être tout à fait complet sur
l'étape d'aujourd'hui depuis chevreuse
l'italien giacomo nizzolo a remporté au
sprint la 2e étape l'allemand max
sharman conserve son maillot jaune du
vélo encore mais cette fois ci assure
piste 6h sur piste était organisée ce
samedi au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le concept 24
équipes de quatre concurrents se sont
affrontés
le classement se fait selon la plus
grande distance parcourue pendant
l'épreuve de six heures plusieurs têtes
d'affiché étaient présentes comme morgan
kneisky quatre fois champion du monde
sur piste
on écoute les différentes réactions à
cette période de l'année on ait jamais
jamais vraiment sûr du temps qui peut
faire dehors donc moi je préférais pas
j'ai toujours privilégié la sécurité
donc je me suis engagé par rapport à ça
et puis la piste c'est quand même on est
tous des passionnés ici donc on est
toujours heureux de me rouler sur piste
l'ambiance est la bonne et puis puis
voilà c'est simplement un plaisir c'est
une épreuve originale une épreuve par
équipes il ya très peu de
deux courses par équipe de six heures et
ça fait une excellente animation pour le
vélodrome et on est très satisfaits
d'avoir de belles équipes avec des
professionnels
[Musique]
il y avait également du football ce
week-end en championnat de national
troyes versailles n'en finit plus de
gagner les versets ils se sont imposés 3
buts à 0 face à torcy dans une rencontre
à sens unique
cette 13e victoire en 18 matches permet
aux joueurs de la cité royale d'être
toujours en tête du classement et que
deux points d'avancé sur ivry dans le
championnat de régionale 2 à seniors
trappe devait recevoir le cosmo taverny
ce week-end pour le compte de la 14e
journée du championnat
mais la rencontre a finalement été
reportée à cause d'un terrain
impraticable trappe pointe toujours à la
11e place sur 12 prochain match dimanche
prochain sur le terrain de champigny
dans le championnat de première division
de district bois d'arcy s'impose 2 à 0
face à sartrouville avricourt domine
carayac grésillons 2 à 1 maurepas est
allé battre bailly bailly noisy sur sa
pelouse 1-0 voisin s'inclinent
lourdement 3-0 face à aubergenville
enfin gargenville bas le pec 2 1
le championnat est toujours dominé par
maurepas l'équipe compte trois petits
points d'avancé sur arles des cours mais
avec un match en plus ont joué at
également dans le championnat à deux
rugbys en division honneur lui ai versé
78 est allé s'imposer 20 à 17 sur le
terrain de paris lors de la 16e journée
du championnat
au classement l'union rugby centre 78 et
5e du championnat à trois petits points
de la quatrième place
le milieu de tableau l'objectif fixé en
début de saison on laisse de côté aléas
ballon ovale pour prendre les ballons de
handball montigny le bretonneux jouer ce
week-end dans le championnat de
nationale 2 féminine et les îles
montaigne se sont largement imposés chez
rose lui hand le score est sans appel 34
à 19 au classement montigny le
bretonneux redescend à la quatrième
place
en basket ont joué sur les parquets de
nationale 3 masculine ce samedi trappe
s'est imposée de justesse face à bihorel
sur le score de 69 à 65 le chesnay
versailles s'est imposé 86 à 64 face à
barjouville de son côté marly le roi
s'est incliné 86 à 73 sur le terrain de
rouen ou classement trappe et 3e le lcv
78 4e et marly le roi un dernier on
passe maintenant notre traditionnel jeu
à détroit question aujourd'hui la
pistarde de l'équipe de france clara
copponi s'est prêté au jeu là notamment
à marquer a récemment l'actualité
sportive en remportant une médaille
d'argent sur l'américaine lors des
derniers championnats du monde à berlin
regardez la séquence
[Musique]
c'est mon frère qui a commencé quand
j'avais 4 ans du coup pas je les suis
depuis je les suive il est en équipe de
france en sprint et moi j'ai fait de
l'endurance
moi j'ai continué et puis depuis j'en
suis là
mon premier titre de championne de
france sur route c'était en 2013 j'étais
minimes 2 et
je courais les cadettes c'est mon
premier titre de championne de france je
l'avais prévoir et avec mon père c'était
le premier aboutissement de ma carrière
[Musique]
les jeux olympiques de tokyo c'est
l'objectif de carrière c'est vraiment
l'aboutissement non j'ai que 21 ans donc
j'espère qu'il m'aura top mais justement
de les faire fermer premier à 21 ans et
mes plus gros objectif dès ma vie on va
maintenant parler de fitness caddie
baradji originaire de
voisins-le-bretonneux a une nouvelle
fois remporté le concours de miss
fitness france c'est la troisième fois
qu'elle remporte cette compétition
nous recevons caddie baradji sur ce
plateau ainsi que sa fille et fatou
bonsoir alors première réaction suite à
cette victoire
nouvelle victoire fierté serai contente
vraiment contente
ce nouveau titre je le voulais vraiment
et donc donc j'ai vraiment fier et
d'avoir ma fille à côté de moi c'est le
top
fatou c'est une joie de voir sa maman à
remporter un titre comme celui là était
très contente et je t'ai pas très étonné
quand on la connaît on sait à quel point
les étonne à fond pour surtout dans le
sport quand elle aime ça n'existe pas
tout donné donc on est content que ça
aboutisse à quelque chose une belle
écharpe l'accord on peut voir justement
beaucoup de sport importe à maman tout
le temps quasiment tout le temps même
quand elles atteignent le travail à la
maison c'est toujours à beautiran on va
faire des tractions bien on va faire des
pompes
si je comprends bien c'est le fruit d'un
travail de plusieurs années
on peut le dire ah oui en fait j'ai
toujours fait du sport donc
effectivement
c'est un accomplissement dans l'ensemble
de ce que j'ai toujours fait en fait
effectivement qu'on adore le sport par
semaine environ
il commence à se décompose une semaine
avec vous pour le coup comme c'est mon
métier en tant que coach sportif est
prof de pièces aux lycéens bas j'en fais
tout le temps
du coup l'avantagent sait que de par mon
métier je pratique énormément et puis
plus mes entraînements personnel je ne
compte pas les heures et dans quelles
vous êtes professeur au ps où exactement
alors au lycée au lycée hôtelier à
guyancourt et à paris après patients et
les élèves ne souffrent pas trop du coup
avec vous j'espère qu'il souffre au
minimum
alors est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter cette compétition miss fitness
france c'est pas forcément une
compétition très connu du grand public
très médiatique parce que vous nous en
dire un peu plus eh ben la compétition à
misfits naissance tout simplement bas
c'est une compétition ça c'est la
première chose c'est pas un concours est
donc en fait on est évaluée uniquement
sur la performance physique
donc moi c'est surtout ça qui me plaît
et un dès le départ la première année
j'y suis allée uniquement parce que
c'était c'était une compétition
aucun jugement sur l'aspect physique sur
l'apparence ou sûr
sur le volume ou la masse musculaire et
c'est uniquement à la performance c'est
ce qui me plaît vraiment donc c'est un
ensemble d'exercices à exécuter dans les
règles de l'art et et à la fin celui qui
a été le plus compétent et de plus
performants gagne les participants
viennent d'où et bien de partout en fait
l'avant le l'intérêt c'est qu'il y à des
sélections au préalable par tous partout
en france et du coup suite aux
sélections il y a le brassage qui permet
en fait de de choisir ceux qui partent
qu'ils participent à la compétition qui
vont finale
qu'est-ce qu'on retrouve comme épreuve
par exemple eh ben on a des pompes mes
épreuves préférées les tractions on a de
la course il ya durable
du développé couché en fait la plupart
des exercices qu'on a retrouvé en salle
de sport en fait on les leon les
retrouve sur cette compétition
tout ce sont plus des époques de force
ou d'endurance finalement moi je dirais
de l'endurance musculaire de résistance
et je pense que pour moi je pense qu'il
s'est quand même essentiellement le
mental qui est mise àl'épreuve parce
qu'on a on a on est souvent tout près du
du candidat la côte et on on a on doit
tenir en fait c'est à dire que on sait
que l'autre est très bon aussi
donc je pour moi c'est au mental qu'on
qu'on y arrive à la fin est ce qu'ils
aient une note quand même sur
l'esthétisme le geste parfait
en fait ils comptent league
le mouvement est mal exécuté tout
simplement il n'est pas pris en compte
donc donc à la fois il faut que le
mouvement sur bien exécuté à chaque fois
il vaut mieux fatou est ce qu'il faut
crier très fort dans les tribunes pour
soutenir maman ou pas du tout ça dépend
ça a été très concentré parfois et il
faut bien encourager d'information et
sinon c'est vrai qu'elle se concentre
plus sur ce qu'elle fait plutôt que sur
ce qui s'y passe n'est pas forcément
négatif par deux fois mais pas forcément
dans ce non non non ça va plus la la
déconcentrer je pense et on n'est pas si
loin plus très facilement la plus
désirée nous verra tout de suite est ce
que tu es surprise ou pas parce qu'elle
arrive à faire lors de ces concours bas
étant donné que je la vois au quotidien
à la maison et en dehors quand on la
voit donner ses cours
non c'est pas étonnant on sait déjà de
ce dont elle est capable donc on se dit
que ma simplement faire plus mieux c'est
de ne plus à fond donc non c'est un
forcément étonnant alors vous avez
remporté trois compétitions du coup miss
france miss miss fitness france 2020
2019 et 2018 quel a été le titre le plus
compliqué à les chercher
et pourquoi eh ben le plus difficile à
aller chercher ça a été cette année le
titre 2020 parce que parce que ça fait
c'est la troisième et du coup au bout de
la troisième on est attendu la première
c'était la surprise on ne connaissait
pas la deuxième du coup on se dit bon il
y avait peut-être un facteur chance est
la troisième du coup les les
concurrentes elle se prépare beaucoup
plus et le niveau est plus élevé cette
année j'ai senti que vraiment
j'étais attendu et que et qu'en face
c'est là où je dit effectivement que
c'est le mental
j'avais pas j'avais pas de répit c'est à
dire que j'avais pas mis une marge ou à
la deuxième candidate et du coup je ne
pouvais pas je pouvais pas relâcher
l'effort donc donc ça s'était très bien
j'ai adoré est ce que tout le monde peut
devenir miss fitness france alors est ce
que tout le monde peut devenir miss
fitness france je dirais pas oui parce
que ce serait un mensonge
mais si on a la volonté si on à
l'entraînement oui fatou est ce que vous
voulez que est ce que tu veux que que
kddi repartent pour une quatrième
couronne un quatrième prix pourquoi pas
je pense que c'est possible et on est
largement capables je pense t-elle dit
est-ce que c'est au programme
alors pour l'instant non encore pour
l'instant non pas du tout parce que
parce que moi mon objectif c'était trois
titres l'objectif est atteint et je
j'aimerais partir sur de nouveaux
objectifs et et je suis à la recherche
d'un nouveau challenge
non pas de quatrième couronne en vue
pour l'instant pour l'instant n'ont pour
l'instant à moins qu'on me dise que la
quatrième il ya autre chose à la à la
clé là en l'occurrence pour l'instant je
suis focalisé sur du coup mon avenir
professionnel sur ce qu'est ce que ce
que va me permettre de développer tout
ce titre etc
merci à vous d'être passé sur ce plateau
quand il y aura à vous suivre évidemment
cali baradji on vous souhaite une
quatrième couronne pourquoi pas dans
quelques années l'année prochaine ou
dans plusieurs années on passe
maintenant notre page agenda
[Musique]
dans cette page agenda une annulation de
dernière minute à cause du coronavirus
le mondial du golf qui devait se tenir
pour la deuxième année consécutive du 19
au 21 mars au parc des expositions de
mantes-la-jolie sur l'île l'aumône
n'aura pas lieu
les organisateurs ont annoncé dans un
communiqué vouloir prendre toutes les
précautions face au risque le mondial du
golf avait attiré 8000 700 visiteurs
l'année dernière et espère en attirer 14
min pour cette édition 2020 un
manque-à-gagner compris entre 100 et 200
mille euros
il devait y avoir également de la course
à pied ce week-end avec la 13e édition
de l'eco trail de paris mais
organisateurs ont décidé de reporter
l'épreuve à cause du courant la virus
cinq distances étaient pourtant
programme dont 1 80 km au départ de
lille de loisirs de saint quentin ligne
ce samedi des centaines de coureurs
présents devaient ensuite rejoindre le
premier étage de la tour eiffel au
rendez-vous et déplacé au samedi à 3
octobre
sinon mondiale du golf et l'eco trail
sont annulés il devrait y avoir du rugby
à ce week end dans le championnat de
fédérale 2 plaisir se déplace sur le
terrain du paris université club ce
dimanche à 15 heures cette rencontre est
très importante pour les plaisirs oies
qui viennent d'enchaîner trois succès en
quatre matches
une bonne dynamique il aura permis de
s'éloigner un peu de la zone de
relégation mais les hommes de sébastien
roques ali auront fort à faire face au
troisième du classement
on jouera également sur les terrains de
fédérale 3 versailles tentera de
repartir de l'avant contre blésois ce
dimanche 15 mars dans leur stade de
porchefontaine un match d'une importance
cruciale pour les joueurs de la cité
royale les versets ils sont à l'heure
actuelle 4e du classement leur
adversaire 5e une victoire permettrait à
versailles de creuser l'écart
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi très belle soirée sur tv
[Musique]